give me your thoughts on the modern
dating market
well i'm too old to really have any
thoughts on it in some sense not from a
personal perspective
well
i don't understand at that level of
detail
you know
i i do know some things that are
happening perhaps at universities where
there are far more girls than boys or
women than men
what happens in those institutions
this is what it looks like anyways
possibly
so females are hypergamous which means
they'll mate across and up
hierarchies
uh socioeconomic hierarchy but
competence hierarchy is really at the
bottom of it
and so when you set up a situation where
there's far more women than there are
men in a given domain say where mate
selection can take place
most of the men still don't do very well
because most of them are still rejected
by women but a small minority of men do
extraordinarily well if you think well
means unlimited sexual access and so
what's happening in the universities is
that
a small minority of men have sexual cart
blush in some sense
and
most men are in the same position that
most young men are always in which is
they're in a state where they're not
particularly desirable to women and then
the women of course are terribly
frustrated because the minority of men
that they would really like to have
long-term relationships with it's it's a
it's a
seller's market for those they're not
settling down that's the sex ratio
hypothesis yeah and the reverse happens
right that you see whoever the most
scarce sex is gets to determine the
rules of the game
so the men if they are in high demand
because the short supply you get
more short-term mating yeah you get um
an
increase in relationship dissatisfaction
from women and when the reverse happens
you get
more dates before
sex you get more long-term mating
you also get more sexual violence in
that situation as well when there is a
surplus of men and a scarcity of women i
think this is
far more unstable societies
you know i was pilloried a few years
back from my comments about enforced
monogamy because they were taken out of
context and twisted in exactly the way
that things like that get twisted now
but
what did you mean by that i mean that
one of the
one human universal is the
construction of societies to
both mandate and reward monogamy and
there's all sorts of reasons for that
it's because it's the best long-term
solution fundamentally
but one of the reasons for that is that
when women are scarce men get violent
now you know that was read to say well i
thought that this society should be
distributing women to undeserving men
which is of course absolutely utterly
preposterous and
bears no relationship whatsoever to
anything i ever said or thought or
anything anyone saying would ever think
or say or has ever thought or said
because i don't know anyone politically
ever who was insane enough to think that
this state should distribute women to
men like that's just never happened so
to be accused of that belief and then
for that to
you know be put forward as a credible
representation of what i thought was
just one of the preposterous things that
has happened to me it's an unfortunate
name enforced monogamy because it's a
term from anthropology right but it what
you mean is
culturally celebrated monogamy
culturally and norms that are supporting
people and raising that opportunity
and supporting and punishing both but
mostly supporting i mean the punishing
is that
there's there's a moral
uh disapproval
applied to say cheating
right to adultery
to especially running around behind your
partner's back if you're married
particularly that but even if you're
even if you're in a long-term stable
relationship it's like well that's all
enforcement it's not police with jack
boots but
that's not the only type of enforcement
it's not the only type of sanction or
threat or punishment or disappropriation
or disgust or contempt or shame or
frustration or disappointment all of
those things and
all of that because monogamy
is a good long-term solution but
in some sense a troublesome short-term
solution
if you have other options
then all of those
elements of social support
let's say
need to be put into place
and that is it as far as i've been able
to determine by looking at the
anthropological literature
norms surrounding monogamy are a human
universal there are exceptions but
they're very there are very specific
situational reasons for those exceptions
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you